Diana.
Arm wrestle me.
Whoa!
Coming in hot.
Uhhh
That’s gonna be a quick no
from Bats.
Then you yield.
I shall spread
news far and wide
of your
cowardly capitulation,
which will call into question
the size of your
sexual member.
Sure.
It's wider than it's long,
but...
let’s not bring body shaming into this
red white and gold Xena.
You dare call me Xena?
I am Princess
Diana of Themyscira
Princess of the Amazons,
known to the world as
Wonder Woman.
Listen,
I'm glad you
brought up your fun little
fighty name,
cause I’ve been wondering
what this weird lady with a
metal headband
is doing on our super team.
Wow!
Are you making
fun of my tiara?
Yeah.
Okay,
with this tiara,
I can understand
any language,
present or future.
Also,
I can throw it
real far.
Okay, so to recap,
you have a metal hat
that’s like Duolingo
and a bad boomerang.
Your whole outfit
It doesn't make sense.
Well you think my outfits stupid?
You took the time to add
ears to your helmet.
Yeah, but
there's little
walkie talkie antennas in there
so i’m wearing hearing aids.
And it goes up into the pointy point
and these are, like, little
AM antennas.
Sometimes I pick up
Wait, wait don't tell me.
That feels
elaborate and unnecessary.
And I don't think
you should criticize
what I'm wearing.
No!
My armor is crafted
by Greek gods.
And at least I don't use it
to give myself fake abs.
Fake abs?!
Fake abs!
You're out of line!
I'm not wearing fake...
hockey...
ab...
There’s abs in here.
Oh
Yeah.
No.
Under here,
there’s abs.
Where?
Well,
under the abs
that are on it.
There's Bruce
Uh huh.
Jiggly Bruce,
and then there's
abs.
What what..
What are those bracelets?
These bracelets
that are made out of the
strongest metal on earth.
Amazonium.
They are so strong
they can stop bullets.
Great.
My wrists have body armor, too
but you know what else does?
My vital organs.
And I'm sorry, but
you're an Amazon
And the metal
that you discovered,
you called it
Amazonium?
That's like
Avatar unobtainium bad.
Oh, really?
How long did it take you
to come up with Batman?
Man, who likes bats.
A surprisingly long time.
My first choice
was Batty McKickin Punch.
I’d have an upside down guy that’d go...
Who are you?
I’d go
Batty McKickin Punch.
But they kept laughing.
I killed a lot of those guys.
I thought you never killed anybody?
It was early years!
I was workshopping.
Sorry.
This?
all all the other reasons I mentioned.
It's why you're
f*ckin fired.
What?
You're f*ckin fired.
There's one thing
you've forgotten about
my lasso.
Oh.
No.
I didn't forget about your lasso.
The whole world
forgot what a lasso is.
You say lasso
to anyone
under 40 in this country?
They all think
you mean
an endlessly
optimistic soccer coach.
It has its uses.
NO!
The Lasso of Hestia
compells you to tell the truth.
It is pointless and painful
to resist.
Oh, this isn't painful
AHH!
It does hurt!
It hurts a surprising amount!
What is your secret
identity?
Bruce Wayne!
But that's just one layer!
I have a deeper
secret identity.
Sh*td*ck Daniels!
Sh*td*ck Daniels is the real me!
Okay.
What is your biggest insecurity?
Bewb Shadow!
No matter how many
girl push ups I do,
there's still a good eclipse
under each of my nips.
What is
your deepest,
darkest secret?
I could’ve saved my parents!
I just had a
game boy at the time!
Oh, God.
Why didn't I put down the Kirby?!
HUHHHN!
Have you ever had a
sexual fantasy
about anyone in the league?
NO!!
YES!!
Flash!
Flash?!
Look, I'm not into dudes
but I'm a porn addict.
It's more about
novelty than what's
actually doing it for me.
Plus, he could give me a handie
so fast
my d*ck would blur in smoke.
GROSS!
I’m gonna tell everyone
on the Justice League
about your
smokin’ h*ndjob fantasy
if you don't
keep me on the team.
I don't care!
I do care!
I define myself by other
people's opinions.
I thought so!
I do an impression
of what I think they want,
and it's exhausting!
psychologically
Draining!
Also
you're f*ckin’ fired.
and you know, I mean it.
Would I lie to you?